[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
end game class as always my name is
killa denby
and tonight i wanted to take you through
some really interesting end games
involving bishops against knights and
the the inspiration for this was
actually a game played
in the chinese championship so we just
finished going over a few games
in that championship uh in the road to
2000
and i wanted to give my guy xiu zhongyu
a chance at redemption here uh as i said
in the previous lecture he's had a
rather up and down tournament
we took a look at two really impressive
games where his opponents
just sort of played very good chess and
managed to beat him
and now we're going to take a look at an
end game where he
actually managed to to come out on top
and we're going to talk about
some really important principles we can
take from this end game
about the the bishop and about knights
in end games and how they work against
each other so let's jump into it
uh playing white is lin yee
another chinese player who i was
actually rather unfamiliar with
but in the chinese championship uh so
very very strong and just a quick note
on chinese players in general
it can be really really difficult to
gauge their actual strength
internationally
because a lot of them the way i think
the the chinese federation sort of works
right now
is there are a lot of internal uh
events for chinese players
to to play in within within the nation
but then
to get to that point where you're
traveling internationally due to things
like you know
being located so far away from places
like europe where many
chess events happen uh players have to
be very very good
before they can really get an
established feed a rating that truly
represents
how strong they are at chess so just a
word of warning if you google some of
these players
uh and you're surprised at their ratings
because
it can be quite misleading but anyways
uh lin yi against zhu
zhongyu let's take a look here so we're
not quite in the end game yet but i
wanted to just show you the the lead up
here
because uh zhu zhongyu makes a pretty
interesting
decision with the black pieces rather
than capture on d5
and go in for what is likely just a
drawn ending
we actually see bishop a6 here so a
willingness
to give up the bishop for the knight in
this position and we'll see if we can
sort of discover
why in a little bit but okay the game
continues with b4 we don't really care
about this
not exactly an end game just yet some
pieces get traded still
and now we see knight c4 and this is our
first
key move that i want to talk about so
knight c4 played in the game but let's
pause here a little bit
and see if we can discover what is going
on in this endgame
should anyone be better i think most of
us can agree that objectively
this game should likely end in a draw
from this starting position
the game should likely end in a draw
difficult to argue with that but if
anybody's going to win
uh who who is it going to be and why and
you know who is it going to be
the answer might be easy because we know
who won but why
why is black somehow practically
potentially on the better side of things
in this position see if you guys can
give me a good reason
96 d1 was correct i tend to disagree
on account of a knight on e2 hanging i
tend to disagree
black because his pieces are better
connected and more
centralized so that that is a fair
observation
to make uh this knight on e5 is sort of
more centralized than any other piece
and you can argue that the knight is
working with the bishop
although this knight perhaps is not
really
influencing these two pieces at all so
that's a fair point
but the um how do you prove an advantage
then
using these these active pieces we see
the move knight c4
but like why play knight c4 what what is
the point what is our goal
in this position
what is our goal we have some activity
but what do we want to do
with that activity
so attack the pawns and yes attack the
pawns
is correct in this case but it's
important to understand why
we aren't attacking the pawns for the
sake of attacking the pawns
we're attacking the pawns to force them
to advance
space can be a very double-edged thing
in the game of chess the more space that
you have
the more difficult it can be to control
all of that space
and with uh the knights in particular
the knights sort of want the pawns to be
drawn towards them
in some cases to to make them easier to
attack and more difficult to defend
so black's goal in creating some
practical chances here is to actually
force these pawns up the board a little
bit and that's why we see the move
knight c4
and after a4 i bet you can guess black's
next move here
chat room black's next move
of course it's going to be the move
knight b2 we want to put pressure on
these pawns
and induce them to move forward so
knight b2
actually creates a threat of capturing
this guy and capturing this guy
so we see bishop c2 by white and now
black to move here black to move how
do we try and prove some advantage
what to do what to do
how can we force these pawns to weaken
themselves further
and yeah pip and chuck has has the right
idea we we want to induce these pawns
further
further up the board so we need to
attack them again and we can do so with
an idea like knight d5 in this case
though
we don't really want to allow this trade
because now we aren't making any
progress at all right and perhaps
it is white who is attacking our pawns
but
bishop takes e2 giving up the bishop for
the knight is the move that you might
expect
given the topic of the lecture but i i
think this would be a move that is
rather difficult for many people to play
in an over-the-board game i think a lot
of people tend to value bishops
very very highly especially in end games
where there's pawns on both sides of the
board
but in this case the bishop on a6 is
just simply worth less than the knight
on c3 and so we see bishop takes a e2
and this is where black starts to take
an objective advantage not just a
practical advantage anymore
by inducing these pawns so far up the
board black is
is objectively a little bit better
perhaps some some pressure in the
position
that white is going to have to look out
for now is it enough to win
probably not but we'll see it is going
to be a difficult position
for white from here on out so really
cool move here bishop takes e2 like i
i feel like we're understating this this
idea here this bishop on a6
pawns on both sides of the board black's
pawns are on dark squares
and black is so so happy to give up this
bishop for this night
really really difficult move i think for
for a lot of people to make in a lecture
a bit easier in a real game i think
you'd be hard-pressed to find somebody
whose first instinct here
is to play bishop takes e2 but that's
what uh zhu zhong yu does
and and it is correct and the reason why
will become a little bit more apparent
after the move knight d5
right we play knight d5 and all of a
sudden
how do you defend your b-pawn and the
answer is of course you do not
and so we get the move b5 and now
we have induced the pawns to be on
uh to be fixed on a color that is the
same square as the bishop and of course
this should be
the knight's goal in any position where
where there is a bishop left on the
board and of course
the bishop's goal should be to put the
pawns on the opposite colors so that
they can attack
the enemy pawns and don't have to
passively defend their
own pawns so b5 by white and black is
now
a bit better the game continues with
knight b4
harassing this bishop a little bit
further notably
almost short on squares with both of
these being covered uh
so bishop b3 the only move to keep
defending this pawn
and now how do we continue well of
course we simply go after this a pawn
now
knight 4 to d3 played in the game knight
d4 and now knight c5
and yeah uh black is potentially
winning upon here because black has been
able to
pull these pawns so far up the board and
and weaken them put them on the same
color as
the bishop so we continue with bishop
to c2 and black does capture this pawn
on
a4 but we see that white's idea
was not simply to just lose a pawn
because knight c6
is in fact a good response here for
white
but what is the difference between you
know losing this pawn on a4
and losing this pawn on a7 and the
answer of course
is that this knight is a lot less comfy
on the a7 square
than this knight is on a4 that that's
why it can
sometimes be useful to draw the the
opponent's pawns forward
rather than for example way back in our
initial position
way way back here even trying to to get
some type of structure
with the pawn on a5 instead like for
example let's say we did this
and played a5 okay let's let's say we
do all these trades take here take here
and play a5 right
by playing a5 we actually are giving
ourselves a bigger weakness than our
opponent
in this case right so in this case the
the main theme i want to show you guys
is this idea of drawing the pawns up the
board so they can be more easily
attacked
not something you see every every game
but something that is useful to keep in
mind okay so knight c6 we just see king
f8 by black getting the king in the game
uh f3 by white is just allowing white's
king easier access to the center
and now black is happy to bring the king
in with king e8 as well
white decides it's time to capture this
pawn on a7
and now we see king d7 king f2
and now knight c3 just a really useful
move
to put pressure on this pawn and keep
this knight sort of locked in
on a7 we see king e3 now
activating the king knight d5 check
bringing the knight
back a little bit and after king to d4
knight e7 and black's idea now
is that this knight on a7 is completely
entombed
and i'm going through this end game a
little bit quickly here
but that's because the the ideas are
actually reasonably simple they're
they're just sort of
difficult to to enact in your own games
so
xu xiangyu does a really really great
job of keeping all these ideas in mind
and executing them perfectly so idea
number one was draw the pawns forward
idea number two uh white's pawn or
black's pawn on a7
is a bit more difficult to capture than
the pawn on a4 because it's so deep
in black's camp that black is able to
play against this knight
and in a sense trap it on the a7 square
notably something like knight to c6 here
would actually not quite
be be good enough to get this knight all
the way back in the game
for example knight back to c3 if you try
knight d4
now knight e6 and this knight is going
to have to move in black is going to win
this pawn or for example
if white tries to take a defend now our
king is simply too close
and black again will win a pawn
okay that's why white leaves the knight
on a7 tries to activate the king
but this allows this idea of knight d5
to e7
and this knight is just stuck in a box
forever
white tries to escape with bishop e4
defending this square
but we just trade our knight for the
bishop now and
build a barrier in front of the white
king
and now there's simply no way to to save
this game
the winning plane is very simple we go
king c7 we go king b7
we go king takes a7 and the game is
is just over white tries e5
but it's far too little too late now
king c7
h4 king b7 take take
knight c6 knight takes c6 and rather
than
b take c6 and lose the king and pawn end
game
white tried to go after the remaining
pawns but of course this is not going to
be
not going to be good enough here and
after a few more moves
uh white resigns why does white resign
well
because black is going to easily bring
the king back to stop these pawns
and the knight is enough to hold the
pawn because it's defending it from
behind
for example king to d7
g5 uh h takes g5
let's say h5 or h takes g either way the
king is
in the box king here
and you just can never you can never
take either of these pieces
so so sad so so sad
uh and yeah that's that's the first game
i want to show you guys
really cool stuff here inducing pawns
forward and then
playing against this knight on a7 and
that was enough to win here because
the bishop was you know passively placed
with pawns stuck on its own color
let's move on to a more direct example
of bishop versus knight now we've seen
a pretty cool example i think uh from
the chinese championship where
zhu zhongyu is so ready to play bishop
takes a2 i think that has to be the move
of the game
giving up the bishop in the end game can
sometimes be a good idea
sometimes two knights are good but
let's move on like i said to a slightly
more traditional type of bishop versus
knight end game
in an older game between maya
shibber danizi and margaretta murasan
did my best there on those names
hopefully i did okay uh
and we're going to start from this
position i'm going to fast forward a bit
as we trade off some pieces
now we have uh queen and bishop against
queen and knight
but i want to simplify things a little
bit further so we we
see white keeping queens on the board
until
this move c5 and this is the one idea i
want to talk about with the queen still
on the board
this is a really really good move by
white here
the reason being we have this bishop
pressuring these pawns on the queen side
but this a7 b6 structure is going to be
difficult to break down
had we for example just treated the
queens immediately
now you have to play like bishop b1 try
to get b4 through it's going to be
rather difficult
whereas with queens on the board we are
able to easily
play the move c5 break down the
structure and create
create a weakness on the queen side to
attack so useful idea here
using the extra material to make another
weakness in the camp
before going for the simplified end game
uh
okay king f7 played in the game now c5
is
very much correct we see b takes and
queen takes right
the queen served its purpose we used it
to create this extra weakness
on a7 here and now we are perfectly fine
uh trading off the queens so queen takes
on c5 played bishop takes on c5
now we see e5 by black
b4 by white is very very natural
creating a threat
a6 is black's attempt to hold things on
the queen side
ready to exchange things off here and
now
i want to to sort of pause and start
start our conversation here uh up to
this point
uh black playing e5 is pretty natural
right this one was backwards we need a
path for the king
and white playing e4 also very natural
trying to roll the majority
black pink is playing a6 essentially
forced otherwise b5 comes
but now white has a decision right it's
it's a free move
you can do any number of things and so
let's pause here
and try to come up with some kind of
winning plan
what what do you think we should do what
types of
changes should we aim for in the
structure
and how do we continue how do we
continue
nico dem says you have heard that queens
work better with knights than bishops
but you always thought it's like 50 50
which piece would be better
and yeah this is sort of uh uh it's it's
kind of funny i think i
actually remember um some conversation
between peter svidler and john
gustafsson
so by the way guys if you don't watch
like chess 24's coverage of a lot of
a lot of these events i highly recommend
checking out
the coverage especially with uh swiddler
and yon
because they just they spew chess
knowledge 24 7.
uh svidler especially just can't stop he
just spews chest knowledge he just
everything out of his mouth is like
chest knowledge um
and they had a chat question that was
what is the
the worst principle that you've heard in
chess that's just never true or that you
learned in chess that's just never true
and i think one of their answers was
that queen and knight works better than
queen and bishop because it's it's just
not true
right it's just not true sometimes it's
true but the bishop
is usually just as good as as the night
so okay everybody wants to start with b5
but this is not a winning plan
maybe a5 and solidify the position so if
there's one move you don't want to play
here it's a5
i am willing to wager this is like the
worst move on the board
uh that doesn't hang just material
outright maybe f4 is worse giving your
opponent a protected pass pawn but
i would i would say a5 is probably worse
the reason for that
is because uh white has no problem
uh winning on the dark squares right
that's where our bishop
reigns supreme but we do have a problem
winning on the light squares
so with a5 now it's going to be
extremely extremely difficult for white
to ever be able to play the move b5
and create a pass pawn uh so you guys
were all saying the move b5
and i think b5 is is perfectly fine it's
it's a great move makes a past pawn
there there's simply no rush for it uh
though
and so b5 is is sort of only half the
plan
only half the plan right and somebody
said you play b5 make a past pawn and
then go after the pawns on dark squares
on the king slide and that is a lot
closer to the plan
but we have to understand that it's it's
not that
simple to go after the pawns on dark
squares on the king side
because things are very much still
in flux on this side of the board right
what's to stop black
given a few free moves from doing this
right and given a few more free moves
from even doing this right and now how
do we win
like how how do you win now right all
the pawns are on light squares you can't
really attack any of them
and it's it's probably just a draw
probably just a draw
so the question then becomes how do you
make sure
that black is left with a weakness on
the king's side
and so at its core when you're playing
with the bishop against the knight
there is one principle in chess that is
usually true and that is the principle
of two weaknesses and and that principle
is
really at its best when you have a
bishop against a knight
the reason for that is pretty intuitive
the bishop is a long-range piece
it can influence both sides of the board
the knight is a short-range piece
and sort of has to to pick one side of
the board to play on
so when you have two weaknesses on
different sides of the board that's when
you can really outplay the knight
and turns out win the game quite easily
so in the game maya chose to start with
the move
of g4 and i like this move a lot because
before the black king has time to really
enter the game you presents
you present black with a rather
difficult question and that question is
what do you do with this pawn on f5
there are a few options you can play g6
you can play f takes g4
you could just play king e6 or you can
play f4 like all of these moves
are are pretty reasonable so let's start
with sort of the most intuitive why not
f takes g4
and i think the reason why maya started
with g4
aside from a move like b5 which again is
is perfectly fine
is because now after takes our king does
have a very direct route into the center
and we have a second weakness we are the
second weakness
is this pawn on e5 now with that being
said
i think this is probably what black
actually should have done
and the reason i think that is because
this weakness
is at close is at least pretty close to
the queen side and
as you can see the knight is still
defending it right the knight can still
influence
things that are happening on the e file
whereas we'll see what happens in the
game
turns out to be a little bit more
difficult for the knight to handle
so f takes g4 maybe black's best try but
white's point now is that you have very
easy access into the center of the board
with the king
and this is going to be a weakness that
does not
go away uh okay why not g6
so i think the idea behind uh
behind white's play here is that if g6
we're going to be able to take
on f5 and actually invade on the king's
side with our king in many cases
and now our weakness that we're going
after is actually going to be the h-pawn
and while it's true that you can push
this pawn forward to h5 in many cases
it is going to be difficult to defend
this pawn
from a king invasion perhaps when
our b-pawn is going to be so threatening
so
all in all uh margaret's move of f4
may seem rather unintuitive but
it's sort of you know none of the
options were good right and f4 is just
one of the options
that she chose now we do see white
continue with b5 this sort of had to
happen at some point
a b5 a b5 knight h4 or sorry knight a5
and now uh the moves of the game
now the moves of the game here white to
play here
what to do what to do
what's to do
what's the plan here chat
pip and chuck says king f2 g
g
uh someone in the chat says g5 a couple
people in the chat are saying
h4 someone says bring the king to e4
so this g5 looks rather strong
so i'm curious curious
curious about these ideas so
king f2 is in fact much much much closer
to a draw
than a win for white which could be
unexpected right the b-pawn looks pretty
strong
but you really do need this second
weakness on the king's side
and so what is black's response to king
f2 well
it's the move g6 right you give black
enough time
and black is going to be able to bring
these pawns to light squares
and you're going to have a very very
very very difficult time
uh breaking through if that is the case
for example
king e2 king e6 king d3
king d5 for example bishop f8 but now
h5 g takes g takes and how do you win
the position
not so clear not so clear right it's
just not
so easy so king f2
not going to be the answer and a lot of
you were saying g5
looks super strong hoping for h takes g5
and like invading somehow and maybe
maybe this is true maybe like you know a
pawn is a pawn here and black is able to
hold on
but even the move h5 here i think is is
probably quite good
for black's holding chances right you
just lock things down
on the king's side you put this pawn
onto g6
and you have the exact same drawing plan
that we saw before
captures not forced in chess however the
move h4
is in fact the correct move here we need
to go h4h5
cementing this weakness on the king's
side
and with this weakness white is going to
be able to win
the game so h4 h5 really really
important stuff here
to be cementing these weaknesses all
right black plays the move g6
and of course what should white do here
what should white do
so yeah h4 g6 though question mark what
to do
g6 threatening h5
threatening h5
and yeah of course we should go h5
anyways now's not the time to bow out
we don't mind having a little bit of a
weakness ourself
because it's more important for us to
have
our own weakness to attack here
we do see the move king f6 and seemingly
black is going to be able to get to our
h5 pawn
first so what does this mean what do we
do
are we going to lose our h5 pawn was
was this h4h5 plan wrong all along
what's to be done here
and what's to be done
bishop d6 bishop d6 you might run into
knight b7 then you have to make a
decision which diagonal do you want to
be on
bishop b6 okay
play on the queen side question mark now
a counter attack on the queen side so
not quite not quite
not quite not quite let me tell you a
secret
what's better than the principle of two
weaknesses
perhaps it's the principle of three
weaknesses right
so uh we're sort of calling this
pawn for white a weakness for black sort
of because
black has to commit resources in this
case a knight to stop the pawn
but black actually has two more
weaknesses aside from that we ensured
that the h6 pawn is going to be weak but
also
this e5 pawn is going to be weak so
of course the best way for white to play
is to actually attack both of these
weaknesses
once with the idea of bishop f8 to g7
and this is how white is able to get a
winning advantage here
white does actually though insert the
moves b6 and knight b7 which doesn't
really change anything
now bishop f8 king g5 and we're not as
worried about
our h5 pawn after the move bishop g7
when now black is unable to defend both
of these pawns
uh black chose to take on h5 and now we
see bishop takes on e5
and white is is going to be winning now
uh why is white winning because black
still has too many weaknesses to deal
with
and we have now opened up paths for our
king
into the game king g5 played king f2
king h or king f5 bishop attacks the
pawn
and once the pawn is induced forward now
we can
bring our king over give a check bring
our king up
and now sorry after king h4
black actually went ahead and resigned
here because there's no way
to defend both of these pawns
and once one of these pawns falls the
the next pawn
will be following suit for example king
f5
king here you can try to pass
but it's just not going to work out very
well for you
for example 985 or something
and uh okay what's what's the best way
to actually like win this
probably we put this guy here and now
your king is forced to defend this f
pawn in the meantime
i will come do this and this and win the
game
and that's the that's the story of this
end game so a few really key things to
take away from this one right
a few really key things uh we started
with queens on the board
which i only wanted to spend a little
bit of time here because queens make
things pretty drastically different
uh than the pure end game but the the
point i wanted to show
is white uses this queen before trading
queens off
in order to play c5 and help advance the
plan
on the queen side a a plan that would
not be possible had we traded on d6 so
important stuff there c5 weakening this
diagonal activating the bishop really
really good
we see bc5 queen c5 queen c5 bishop c5
and now uh b4 and g4
i i wanted to mention as as a really
great move this is sort of great move
number two by white you
attack the pawn on the light square and
you force your opponent to make an
awkward decision before they are sort of
in their ideal setup black chose to play
the move f4
and now b5 is rather obvious but the
really really key point here
is h4h5 making sure blank is left with
weaknesses on dark squares
that can be easily attacked and that is
how
maya goes on to win this game h4h5
and here the the rest is history bishop
f8 to g7
black cannot defend both pawns and then
here
uh black still cannot defend both pawns
as we see after kh4
with bishop g5 to follow when one of the
pawns falls
then we bring our bishop over to this
square
attack f4 and bring our king in and win
the game
okay so questions on this endgame before
we move on to
to a third
all right nico says sometimes people say
that you should keep your pawns on the
color of your bishop or the opposite
color
either one i think is more nonsense than
bishop and queen versus knight and queen
so there are the confusion arises
because there are are different rules
for different points in the game
so often times in
middle games it's really really useful
to use your pawns to make up for a
bishop that you lack and that your
opponent has
so what that means is you use your pawns
to guard the dark squares
if you don't have a dark square bishop
in your opponent does now that involves
putting your pawns in dark squares in
the middle game however when you
transition to more of an
end game that sort of reverses now all
of a sudden
if your pawns are all on dark squares
that bishop is able to attack them
whereas earlier with more pieces on the
board that wasn't exactly relevant
because there are more important things
going on with the pieces but in an
endgame
then the bishop becomes more of an act
of attacking piece against those pawns
and that's why you want them on the
opposite color
namely when you are playing with the
bishop you want to have peace
activity you want to be active not
passive and the way to do that
is to be able to attack your opponent's
pawns and you can only do that if
they're on the same color as your bishop
can't ever attack a pawn it's not on the
same color as your bishop
so that rule has a little bit more sense
to it it's just that it does change
depending on what phase of the game
you're in
and of course the specifics can always
get in the way
but good question good question
what was the what was the best option
for black against g4 so it's it's tough
to say
uh it is tough to say i think perhaps
this
was a little bit of a better try uh
going king e6 here
but like honestly things are pretty
tough already like white is still going
to go h4 h5
but leaving yourself with a weakness on
g7 might actually be a bit more
manageable than a weakness on
h6 because this king can can sort of
jump back and forth between these
squares a bit more easily honestly
though
this is just going to be a tough
position for black to deal with
like g6 i think you just run into the
same exact problem as you had last time
upon being on f5 and sub f4 doesn't
actually change all that much
and uh yeah f takes g is really the only
other option
which maybe is a bit better but i think
black is going to have a tough time
regardless
black has a passer in this position well
it's it's not a very useful passer
right not a very useful password because
if we ever get too crazy and put our
king here
all of a sudden bishop f8 lands on the
board and we're losing losing pawns
right just just losing pawns
so it's more of a weakness than a than a
passer
good questions though let us move along
to our next example here which is going
to be in a game between
vasily smith love and bakuti
gurganidzi cootie
gurganinzi everybody's favorite player
from from chess history of course
um okay let's take a look though
we are a few moves out from the end game
i want to talk about with the bishop
versus the knight
we have bishop takes e6 played on the
board and our rooks start to disappear
rookie 7 going after this pawn rookie
one
tactically responding to the threat
knight c5 bishop c4
and g5 played by black
black getting perhaps a little bit of a
head start
on this idea of putting the pawns on the
opposite color as the bishop useful to
notice
and then we see some tactics that result
in the rooks coming off the board
d2 rook d1 and these pawns disappear
now h5 by black we see a6
by white taking the maximum amount of
space here
g4 by black black is employing the
strategy where when you are
the worst side in an endgame you want to
try and trade as many pawns as
possible in order to get closer to a
purely drawn end game where you can
sacrifice something for the remaining
pawn
and perhaps for this reason as well in
that previous example
f takes g4 would have been better but
regardless here we are
now rook d6 is played we see
takes on f3 king takes f3 we see a check
king e3 rook f6 takes and takes
so chat room white to move here
this should be a little bit more clear
than the previous example
but wait to move here what do we do what
to do
white to move
g4 went too far maybe h4 was better so
yeah we'll jump back
and see if black could play better but
let's focus on winning this with white
first
let's focus on winning this
so yeah you guys have have the right
idea uh
i i might have led you the tiniest bit
of stray
uh by showing you this position h4 is is
totally winning and
is of course the right idea but perhaps
the the nuanced best move is actually to
play king d4 first as played in the game
but h4 immediately this is the right
idea it's winning here it's absolutely
correct great job everybody you have to
cement this pawn
on the light square if you want to win
now this might be
a little bit in contrast to the previous
position where i said a5 was like the
worst move
on the board if you remember i'm going
to flip back really quick
a5 in this position i said was the worst
move ever and it seems like
you know you're giving yourself the same
type of backward pawn situation
uh but it really couldn't be further
from the truth here
because our bishop is on the opposite
color so we don't have much of an issue
of controlling the g4 square so h4
fantastic move great idea and the point
is now
black just has an indefensible weakness
and is going to lose the game shortly
why do i say king d4 might be the nuance
slightly better move well because
it gains a tempo on the knight and then
we can do
the the exact same idea here of h4
what's the difference
well there's no king e5 that that's the
only difference
and of course this doesn't matter too
much because uh
because because white is still still
just winning right white's just winning
here
but let's take a look at what happened
in the game in the game white played
king d4 first which is great
knight d7 and then white played king d5
then white played king d5 just
activating the king very you know simple
stuff
simple king forward win game but
what should black play here what should
black play here
and yeah michael has the the perfect
idea here
black plays the move h4 and uh if you
ask a computer
it'll tell you that white is like plus
three
which is true white is like plus three
the problem is
plus three is not really plus a billion
and you need to be plus a billion
in these end games in order to win right
plus three is not checkmate
okay plus three means you're able to win
a piece somehow
so white might be able to win a piece
somehow but white
may not be able to win the game as we'll
see uh
in a little bit here so of course of
course of course
white should have taken this opportunity
to play the move h4
you play h4 you cement this pawn in h5
you followed up with bishop b2
you win the game game winner right there
game winner but hold on a second
like this looks like a pretty good
position still for white right like this
this looks pretty good this pawn's
pretty weak
you know we have we have we can make a
past pawn whenever we want on the king's
side
why isn't this winning for white
and now and now i shall flip the board
don't don't you hate it don't you hate
flipping the board let's play for black
now okay we found the move
h4 and we are cruising
but there's still work to be done here
so
let's come up with a drawing
plan for black how should we organize
our forces with the black pieces in
order to draw
this game
okay everybody is saying knight b6 and
trade okay
i don't know if you are fully aware of
how king and pawn and games work
but in general in king and pawn end
games okay well first of all
it's not our turn so i should play
another move bishop e2 is on the board
but like let's say white played h3 like
this is
probably losing right yeah this is
so not that in the game that white plays
bishop e2 so sorry i should have been
giving you the position
with with it to be your move so you know
what your opponent did
you're going to sacrifice the knight for
the a pawn and play h3 so the problem is
in chess captures are not forced okay
captures are not forced this is a big
problem in chess
so you never are able to win the end
game after h3 because white is able to
play g
or draw the end game because white is
able to play g3
so we need a better plan
we need a better plan
so let me let you in on a little bit of
a secret here
okay a little bit of a secret this is
why we do all those super boring
technical lectures
on technical end games with like no
pieces on the board okay
that's why we do those lectures because
they help you in positions
like this so let me ask you guys a
question
okay let me ask you guys a question
all right picture this picture this
you go e7 right plays g4
we take it they take it
we go knight f6 check
they go king c6 we go here
they go g4 what move are you going to
play what move
are you going to play also wait a second
wait a second
okay never mind never mind they waste a
move you go king here
now they play g4 what move are you going
to play what move are you going to play
got the position slightly wrong
yeah you take the pawn and draw this
would have been more
more convincing had i not messed up the
position so of course
you can't actually take the pawn here
because bishop takes g4
locks your king out of the corner and
you actually do lose but
uh this position
is actually a draw uh you you can't
force the black king out of the corner
when we have the the pawn here on a7
doesn't matter that the rook
that that the pawn is of the the correct
color winning square
you just can't force this king out you
can't force them away you can't do it
just can't do it you can try but you
just can't do it
you just can't do it how do you get them
out of there how do you get them out
you can't you can't do it gotta
stalemate him
gotta stalemate the king so that is the
crux
of black's drawing idea here the crux of
black's drawing idea
is that if white does try to make this
past pawn on the king's side
we always have this kind of bailout
option
where we are able to sacrifice the
knight for the g-pawn
and uh can then draw the game
now let me ask you a second question
okay
knight f8 played in the game what
happens
if white comes and takes the a pawn this
is
critical idea number two for black to be
able to draw this game
what happens here
yeah chess king is still on this h3 idea
to get the wrong pun but
captures they're not forced okay they're
not
forced i don't know who told you that
white had to take this pawn but white
doesn't have to take that pawn
and then you're going to lose another
pawn and oh my god then you're really
losing
so now if we played in the game what do
we do if white comes
and takes our a pawn
and yeah the chat has the right idea
here uh
you simply trap the king
and then he can never escape and now
what happens if g4
or g3 well we take it
and we go 96
and we blockade the pawn and then we
move back and forth forever
right the bishop can dominate the knight
pretty well but it can't take away
all of these squares okay you know it's
it's a pretty good piece of dominating
the knight but even if you put it on d5
i still have a square i can pass on and
that's good enough for a draw
and white draws with a plus three
position according to the computer
really powerful stuff uh so
what does that leave white with well
that that doesn't really leave white
with a plan we we have
uh our way of of stopping both ideas so
all that remains
is making sure that we don't sort of
let the white king go crazy and and win
this pawn for free somehow so that's why
you see the move
knight f8 because black's king is
actually pretty well placed
if white tries to go this way we can
follow suit
and if white tries to go this way we can
also follow suit
so king d king e4 played in the game
king g5 played by black
and king d5 king of six bishop g4
black passes with the knight bishop f3
we see a check and black plays 96
keeping the king still boxed out bishop
b2 came back to g5
king e5 knight f4
and white continues to try the second
the white king heads to the d file by
the way you see the black king appear on
the f file
it would be a pretty huge mistake to
play another knight move here and allow
the king to capture
we need our king one file away so we can
trap him on the a file
and now
they played on and they played on and
they played on
and black did nothing and then white
played g3
but of course this is not enough
to win the chess game as we have
discussed
and the last move of the game black
finally finds a way to sacrifice the
knight for g
pawn and they agreed to a draw here of
course
we have this basic draw that we
discussed earlier
with the king in the corner and that's
it that's a drawn game
so all because white didn't play the
move h4
uh we see black able to draw this
position
so really instructive stuff uh
okay any questions on this endgame
questions on that h4 move questions on
how black is actually able
able to draw in the end before we call
it a night here and head over to twitch
what if minor pieces could promote in
chess i'm not qualified to answer this
question so i will decline to answer
all in all maybe a6 by white was a
mistake
uh now you're you're testing my my
knowledge of all this theory uh
yeah i want to say maybe a6 was a
mistake but
it doesn't actually matter a6 is
irrelevant okay a6 doesn't matter
because because because because
black white should have played h4 here
and won the game and when white played
a6 rooks were on the board and that's
sort of a drastically different
situation than when works are off the
board
so i don't know if you can say a6 was
was a key mistake
because white had a winning position
right so
definitely i would say the mistake comes
when white throws away the winning
position
that would be my argument although i do
i would say
h4 here is a bit better all right well i
am going
ahead uh going to go ahead and call it
quits here guys
thank you so much for joining me for
these two lectures here tonight
uh the fun is going to continue live on
twitch directly after this with analyze
your games
if you haven't had enough chests yet
tonight i would recommend
heading over and checking it out if you
have
then i totally understand or if you're
just watching the replay
i want to say thank you very much for
joining me here tonight as always my
name is caleb denby
and i will see you next time
you